[Music]
all right um what's going on well
besides massive technical difficulties
nothing i'm good all right recording on
one airpod today because we're having
mic problems yeah there's no you know
that's a man's last stand when he's down
to his last airpod
it's like remember the alamo is what's
going on right now
in my ears
i'm out here at marathon ranch my ranch
what does this angle here this looks
good right
that looks good and i really like how
much you're trying to brand this as
marathon ranch rather than just be like
i'm at my house by my ranch my ranch
house i have so if people like this they
can go to
marathonranch.com it's not set up now
but i'll do it well uh if you go to
marathon ranch it'll auto direct to the
airbnb listing i got my first guest uh
they left the other day
did you like spruce it up for them and
like kind of give them the five-star
treatment i didn't but someone did yeah
oh okay all right um
do you want to can i get into a story
that interests me a ton and i think uh
you might know more information about it
than is public but um but maybe not
okay go for it all right so i gotta give
a shout out to haley at rock health i
saw this on her twitter so there it's
about this company called you biome
which you probably know a little bit
about it at a high level because it was
in the press for uh kind of being like a
theranos type of thing but i actually
learned a little bit more information
about it and this story is way
underplayed so check this out
you biome was founded by this woman
named jessica rickman and zac opti who
the founders and so basically what it
was was
they measured different parts of your
body and
to tell you all about your gut and your
biome and things like that in other
words they basically measured your poop
so you poop at home i think you could
swab your vagina you could poop and then
maybe swab your cheek and then you mail
it in and it tells you all about your
which one did you choose
that's funny
that's the worst 105 but i still got it
so uh so anyway you uh you could swap
whatever you wanted and they would you
mail it in and it tells you all about
your biome which i'm not sure what that
tells you but it's supposed to be really
important and so when they kicked things
off
they did a crown crowd funding campaign
they raised three 300 thousand dollars
they also were backed by yc which is a
big deal and then they raised over 100
million dollars from a bunch of people
including andreessen horowitz so tier
one investors this woman who started it
jessica she's this young woman in the
tech space in the tech uh medical space
and she's under 30 so she wins forbes 30
under 30. you see her all over
conferences if you google her name some
of the first pictures of course you're
going to see her on the ted stage
speaking at conferences whatever
but once they get a little bit of pop
once they start getting a little bit
popular people start saying like you
know is this really right and so the
first thing is a lot of people are like
a lot of people in the uh in the space
the experts they say something like you
know the way they're tracking and
storing your data it's like it's a
pretty big deal that we know all about
your your gut health there's a lot of
like identifying information there and
the way you're storing that that's not
really good second of all we've been
trying to crack this whole thing where
you can just swab your cheek or your
poop or whatever and mail it in and get
all these results we've been trying to
do that and it's really challenging and
i don't know how you guys are doing it
and then about two years after they
started i think they started the company
in like
2016 16 ish
2015 but 2017's when they got this press
around 2017
this article comes out
turns out she completely lied about her
age so jessica so if you scroll down
sean in the document i have her picture
that she actually had in forbes
what does what does she look like to you
[Music]
uh i would have said like mid-thirties
okay
thirty-three four thirty-five something
like that in that picture she's like 42
and so when she won the forbes 30 under
30 she was actually 42
which is
which is crazy and so people start once
people find out about that
they realize that look what else is
there a lot what else are they lying
about and so turns out that they were
billing patients without their consent
meaning
doctors would order this after you buy
them would pressure doctors into
ordering these kits and then they would
charge the doctor which would pay them
three thousand dollars and then they
would do like a recurring thing so they
kept charging the doctors which then
medicare medicaid whatever it is they
were one footing the bill and so in 2019
this is where you probably know the
story a little bit in 2019 the fbi
raided their offices and basically weeks
later the whole company shuts down and
she goes to court and there's a 33-page
indictment that says the founders uh
committed tons of federal crimes
including conspiracy to commit
securities fraud fraud conspiracy to
commit health care fraud and money
laundering because by the way at this
point they had taken 12 million dollars
of shares the two founders off the table
so that went straight to their pocket of
the hundreds of millions of dollars that
they raised and so
they go to uh trial they're guilty so
they go to jail right
definitely not turns out
jessica marries her co-founder who's a
german national he's a german citizen
and they flee to germany and at this
point people can't really find out where
they are and because of the way that the
law works they it's not really easy to
extradite them back to america and so as
of now
they basically have gotten away with it
you know reputation's ruined but
they're not going to i think they face
up to 95 years in prison they're they're
and they've totally gotten away with it
and this story until i saw this tweet i
remembered it but it's totally been
downplayed and this woman and her
partner are totally they totally have
gotten away with it so far
yeah they're at like oktoberfest right
now uh having a great time well you know
there's some guy in jail listening to
this podcast and he's like you know
there for for 15 years he sold like 1.1
grams of weed and he's like and he's
like making blind in his toilet
exactly god making toilet wine he's
sitting in jail right now serving you
know a double life sentence and
these guys are at oktoberfest right now
after defrauding the public the patients
the medical system and then running away
from the country right that's that's
pretty much what happened here it's a
pretty crazy story and i remember when
this happened i knew somebody who was
working there
and then it was or somebody who i think
he had worked there and he was like this
ain't right he kind of left really
quickly
and then i remember because their their
offices i think in san francisco and it
just got raided and shut down like all
in one day and this was like kind of
like a hyped startup that was like a yc
backed biotech
you know gonna save lives type of
startup and then all of a sudden poof
gone yeah and we didn't talk about it
you know it kind of disappeared for the
last two years the pandemic but i was
researching it and it's just
pretty amazing and then there's this
other part which is the lawyers who are
representing them america is like hey
you guys you guys got to come back here
and they're saying she can't travel
because of some unnamed health condition
so they like got all these excuses as to
why they can't come back to america and
as of now [__]
yeah yeah i think i wonder if you could
find that out in her poop as of now like
they're
they're they're they've won
wow that's a that's kind of amazing you
know
pretty good timing for them but this
whole pandemic thing you know and then
there knows there's just like higher
profile frauds that like came out
shortly after like the one we were
talking about but the crypto like money
laundering husband and wife yeah you
knew you had met
they're like the just like the flashier
version of these guys
yeah somehow this happened
it's it's kind of i i
i've been going down a rabbit hole of
these recently so i watched this
documentary on netflix
the other day have you seen this it's
called
um
don't tell the truth or someone's
telling the truth or trust no no trust
no one i think this is called
is it like change do you see this on
netflix but there's like one on enron
and there's one on other things or is
this just on crypto no no no this is
like just their movie you got it so
basically this is a crazy story dude
check this out great movie by the way if
you want to watch the movie you probably
want to skip some of this because it's
spoiler but like
i'm just gonna say it because i'm not
gonna like you know save this movie
forever else all right so
basically back in like 2013 14 15
this this guy in canada creates a like
bitcoin he's like interested in bitcoin
bitcoin was like pretty kind of like
green at the time it had it's like first
run-up where it like hit a thousand
dollars and stuff like that
and this guy creates an exchange in
canada he's like oh it's really hard to
buy cryptocurrency in canada so it
creates this exchange called quadriga
quadriga cx
and so quadriga becomes the largest
exchange in canada and there's this one
the guy's like then pull us pull this
guy up on on the screen chair thinks
that sam could see it but basically he's
like this
blond-haired kind of like just nerdy
looking guy and in fact he does these
interviews and they're like are we
talking to the next mark zuckerberg and
he's like ha ha well you know i don't
know about that but we do want to make
positive impact in the world and um and
you know so he's just a soft-spoken
nerdy guy
and he's the founder of this thing and
it's whatever bitcoin keeps growing and
and uh
in value then like other currencies come
out yeah this is the guy yeah dude he
looks like butters from south park
and he talks like him too according to
your impression
my impression by the way sounds nothing
like the guy that was uh you know i just
made one up there so
he anyway so all of a sudden one day
people go to quadriga.com or whatever
this website is
gone
it's just like a 404 page
oh quadriga must be down
is it just me you know it seems like
everyone's having this issue all right
is it just down or
is it gone
the website is gone where is where does
the website go where'd the exchange go
where is my money and all of a sudden
people realize that
all of the customer funds are gone 215
million dollars of crypto is like not
accounted for and this is before the
run-up right now this would be like
billions of dollars worth of
of that same crypto but at the time this
is you know 20 whatever 16 17 18
something like that um your crypto
wasn't as uh you know bitcoin was you
know much much lower back then
and so
everyone's like what the hell happened
then news comes out
the founder of quadriga died suddenly on
a trip in india
and he had the private keys
to the crypto and like he died and no
one else knew the keys and
the crypto is now inaccessible i
remember this happened maybe three years
ago right
and so yeah exactly so people are like
what the [__] and so a bunch of
customers are like dude i had ten
thousand dollars i had a hundred
thousand dollars i had a million dollars
there and people are pissed so they get
in a telegram group and they're like
oh my god like i hope they're gonna be
able to recover this and that kind of
like a day goes by and nothing comes out
and like the wife's estate that is the
wife post on facebook like
um you know my husband has died suddenly
on this trip to india
um
you know unfortunately
like we lost the keys and it's like
jennifer robertson the the executor of
the estate or something like that
that was his wife that's how she signed
it and people were like that's really
weird message like he died a month ago
and they just posted this now
and like where the [__] the money and
like
really this this like the number one
exchange in canada it was just one guy
had all the private keys like that seems
so weird
and um
so they start to say like how do we know
he's dead how did we know he didn't just
pull off what's called an exit scam
encryption roll up that body
yeah exactly and so literally that's
what they do so they get in a telegram
group together all these customers they
start basically crowd sourcing the
investigation first they report to the
authorities authorities do nothing
they're just like hey
you know we can't really yeah
cryptocurrency has all kinds of risks
where was he buried
so he's and he dies in india and they
basically they do come back and have a
funeral here
and they're like what's the they're so
they're like hey was anybody at the
funeral blah blah then they like they
get in touch with like what the wife's
like sister they're like was the funeral
uh was the casket open or closed they're
like closed casket and they're like ah
and then like so that people just start
getting like in what what was he what
did he die from
uh he died from crohn's disease they
were like oh he a sudden uh
gastro you know complication uh from
somebody with crohn's disease and people
like dude i'm looking this up you don't
die of crohn's disease like it's very
very rare to just suddenly die did they
call the hospital where he went to
so then so they're contacting the local
journalists they send somebody out to
india they go find this it's like a
needle in a haystack like oh is there a
white man who had like diarrhea in india
it's like yeah all white people in india
have diarrhea dude like you know how
you're gonna find this guy
everyone gets number three when they go
there
exactly it's gotta die to number three
and so
they but they eventually find the doctor
they go to the doctor and they're like
hey do you
we heard there's a there's a death
certificate for somebody who who died
here but like there's a so they're like
there is a death certificate okay so we
think he died then people like you you
can fake death certificates like you can
pay there's a black market for death
certificates and so they're like talking
about that then they're like all right
they go find the doctor they ask the
doctor the doctor's like yes i remember
it guy came in was having like you know
upset stomach we kept a mirror overnight
for fluids and then he suddenly like had
a heart attack and died like kind of
like he you know he suddenly got much
worse and he died
and they were like okay was there an
autopsy he's like no there was no
autopsy done very that's weird why was
there no autopsy done and like so
there's there's still like a question
mark but you know the journalist comes
back says it look does
there's no reason to believe that he's
not dead uh like you know
this is what happened and so there's
there's rumors that he went and got
plastic surgery changed his face and
he's living somewhere in the bermuda
triangle somewhere there's some random
rumors like that
and there's like all these people trying
to like crowdsource this and they're
like wait a minute the wife like the
wife got like 12 million dollars of real
estate
they start looking into the wife
and they're like how come her name is
what it is like how come she doesn't
have his last name
how come there's no record of her name
before this oh she changed her name
recently she's changed her name three
times in the last year why did she go
from you know whatever aaron griffith to
aaron jacobs to aaron robertson like
that doesn't make sense and like then
they find that like the ex-husband
somebody with the same last name
griffith or whatever like died also of
mysterious causes in canada and they're
like oh did you poison him and they're
like what's going on and so nobody knows
what actually went down
but this and then there's like but
because it's crypto it's all on all the
transactions of the blockchain sorry so
the whole time i'm watching this movie
i'm like wait a minute but like if the
guy's alive and he tried to steal the
money you'll see the money moving if the
money's moving somebody has the keys and
like what ended up happening was
actually that
the guy oh there's even more to the
story so they go look into this guy
they're like all right who is this guy
and they find like an er like you know
the same way the silk road guy got
caught they find an early
like
record or mention of the name
um on this like black hat hacker forum
so they go to this black hat forum which
is where hackers hang out black hat
means you sort of do the like the white
hat which is like you find bugs you tell
the company there's gray hat which is
like you find an exploit you kind of use
it but it's not illegal and black hat's
like straight up illegal
and they find this guy
under this uh name like scepter or
something like that on this black hat
forum and he had been running multiple
scams and they linked this founder that
that guy i showed you butters they show
they linked him to this guy scepter
because he has the same name
like they found his his email address in
the forum and his official name because
he had like ordered some product to put
in his name and address and it was like
his actual full name and that and so
they like figured out that he is scepter
he had he was a he was a scammer and
then they find one key thing which is
that
um
some the the the blockchain forensics
guy basically he's like oh you know like
these cases you sort of hit a dead end
and it can be like that for years but
then there's one bit of information that
comes out that just cracks the case he's
like that's what happened we got one bit
of information about this scepter guy
that went and cracked the case because
then we found a user on the network
called scepter we noticed
that he basically what was happening was
a customer would come to cardigan they
would buy bitcoin
and he was just in the database send
them bitcoin like send them
quote-unquote bitcoin into their account
but there was no actual bitcoin he was
just like funding that account with a a
fake amount of bitcoin that wasn't
actually on the bitcoin blockchain and
he would just take their money he would
go go to other exchanges and actually
buy bitcoin with it and like he said he
was funneling money himself so the whole
time these users thought they had crypto
in their account but they never did so
where's the money now every crypto
person's worst nightmare well so so
that's what i'm saying is like it wasn't
that the site went down and they lost
the keys to this one wallet that had 200
million in it is that it was actually
there the whole time it was never there
there was no wallet there there was no
there were never
if you could always track it so where is
it now
so
that money every time a customer imagine
basically it wasn't ever one bit of
money it's like every time a customer
bought
he would go make a small transaction on
one of ten exchanges and you don't know
who's who's doing that because it's all
under different account name stuff like
that so basically he like laundered the
money very effectively during that so
all that money is gone
and so is this crazy movie what do you
think happened is he alive or did the
wife kill him
oh well the other crazy part is
back in that black hat forum he had um
he had partnered up with her he had
reached out to this other guy michael
patron and michael patron uh was another
guy on the black platform another
scammer and they had built they had
launched they had co-founded it together
actually quadriga
and then they got in a big disagreement
and then michael patron left after you
know some number of years um and then it
was just this this dude doing it so one
theory is that that guy
that guy killed him
uh another theory is the other wife
killed him in others he killed himself
because he thought he was gonna get
caught
another is that he's alive nobody knows
which of those it is what do you think
i believe uh i think the guy's alive
based on the like the like the like the
movie basically took the indian doctor's
word as like i remember this guy coming
in yup he had complications he died we
did no autopsy and i remember it all you
know like
i feel like they
vastly underestimated the amount of
corruption you can get in india for like
ten dollars
and so um
so you know i i think this guy is
probably
just for the people listening for the
people listening sean's indian
right
yeah exactly
uh so dude
if you're
is there if you're if you fake your own
death let's you fake your own death and
you have a billion dollars as low as 150
million dollars however much was stolen
as high as a billion dollars
what's even the point of having that
money if you're fake dead like how do
you ball out and like how do you live
what's the point of it
and what did his mom and dad say
most importantly how how ashamed are
your parents well like did they were
they devastated
they didn't talk to mom dad they talked
to the wife's sister uh and she was like
you know she's like we now look like
huge liars because at first we were like
she had nothing to do with this
um and he was a good guy he was so sweet
he was so romantic like you know he's
not capable of like crime like if he
died he died like you guys are horrible
conspiracy theorists and then it like
came out that no he clearly scammed and
then it's like
well we were wrong about the first part
saying he didn't scam so now nobody
believes us that a she wasn't in on it
or b that he's not like that he's dead
so we kind of lost our credit but we
look like liars now just because we
didn't really know here's what i've
learned here's what i've learned
studying conspiracy theories and
watching like every episode of dateline
ever which is
people tend to be very bad at keeping
secrets and so if there's more that a
couple people who are involved in this
it typically comes out even if it's a
long time things come out um and so that
whenever i hear these i'm like it could
just be the simplest thing is that he
did in fact die it's really hard to keep
that secret to keep that secret would be
so challenging
right
yeah i i'm kind of with you like i think
maybe it's possible he did suddenly die
or he got killed uh you know like one of
those two or committed suicide yeah
those are all possible but man dude just
ima like can you even put yourself in
the mind of
to to execute on this elaborate scheme
like you're literally just duping like
millions of customers simultaneously
sitting in your room on your laptop just
straight stealing from everybody like
it's just a crazy level of like
you know like a sociopath to be able to
do something like that it's really wild
to me have you read about bernie madoff
at
all uh no
so basically he um i can't think of a
good analogy right now
but basically yeah he ran a ponzi was a
i think it was like 56 billion dollars
but you and i were both too young to
probably watching the news when it
happened i think i was in high school or
grade school i don't remember but um
anyway he it was like a 58 billion
dollar ponzi scheme and he had been
running it for 40 years and the
equivalent of it i think it'd almost be
like um you know jamie dimon at um
uh morgan stanley jacob morgan or
whatever jp morgan like a figurehead
like that
because at at one point when even when
he got arrested i believe bernie madoff
was the chairman of either the nasdaq or
maybe he was chairman of the sec like uh
like he was the chairman who and it was
his job to make sure that fraud didn't
exist and when he got busted it was this
massive ring this or this massive fraud
of like 58 billion dollars i think i
think i think it was in the 50s of
billions of dollars so just massive and
he'd been doing this for 40 years it's
and and they're like why did you keep
going he's like once i was in i just
couldn't back out i was in
so dude i guess i have another one a
more modern day a current one of these
that's unraveling as we speak
did i okay so
did i talk about this this video of the
of the ceo of fast i think i did way
back in the day on the pod did i talk
about this
video people were tweeting at us saying
we called it and i don't remember what
we what we talked about with fast but
basically
fast.com it's a quick checkout so
basically if you go to a website i don't
even know what websites like honest
company or something and you want to buy
diapers it's like a universal checkout
button basically which is what paypal is
yeah it saves your information and so
you can go to another website and do
this right so we uh we are the founder
of bolt come on here i invest in bolt
bolt does the same thing but like with a
lot of actual users and revenue
fast basically like i don't know uh
this was maybe two years ago that this
was happening maybe three years ago
where all of a sudden on twitter there
was this new company fast it had the
domain i think i had the domain fast.com
i think it has fast.com but it
definitely had the twitter handle fast
yeah and all of a sudden there was this
guy
dom you would see this guy d-o-m-m dom
and it was like i'm the ceo fast before
this i grew my business to 50 million um
now i'm doing now i'm you know
working on fast and then basically they
were just like this twitter [__] hype
machine it's like this girl joined as
the ceo and she looked cool and she was
had a background at uber or something
like that and she was the new ceo of
fast and fast would talk about how how
fast their checkout was right and how
big of a problem this was and they were
talking about like you know they're um
they would you know they were making
swag and they were like basically
raising money and they were you know he
could just tweet out at one point he
like sponsored like a sea doo race team
or something like that like there was
like a press event where he was on a
sea-doo with like a professional sea-doo
guy doing that
yeah
we need to literally put that in this
episode so ben can you google this uh uh
i i know how i'm gonna get you a link
real quick but it was like a guy doing
flips on a fast sidoo the greatest promo
ever word you're saying by the way i've
never heard that
like uh
it's like kleenex it's the brand but a
lot of uh
okay so so ben go go to this link and
we're gonna we need to watch this video
together in a second here but let me
just set up the rest of the context so
fast goes and fast starts raising money
um and they raised let me just pull it
up
so
closer
stripe they raised from
big from shopify as well i might be
wrong on that but they raised um
yeah so they raised from stripe uh early
on i think they raised
this says christmas says almost oh of
over a hundred million dollars all right
so they raised 100 million dollars
series b they had a 20 million dollar
series a
and um
and so
and so this was you know fast was like a
darling in fact i met this guy from
india this indian uh engineer and he
goes
he had worked at like i don't know
stripe and now he was working at fast
and i was like oh like you want to you
want to be an entrepreneur someday he's
like yeah i'm just right right now i'm
just like i'm just collecting i'm just
collecting my stamps on my passport he
goes in india he's like in india if they
see that you worked at stripe and you
worked it fast and you worked it like
name one up pinterest one other like one
name company that they've heard of like
oh you're you must be like super smart
that's harvard iit that's like a
pedigree right there and so he was
collecting his fast stamp at the time
and i remember asking i was like i was
like so is it legit um because like
they'd raised over you know nearly 200
million dollars and i was like
um
you know is it like awesome like is it
growing really fast are there users i
don't know anyone who uses it and he's
like no there's no users yet and the ceo
the red flag number
you know i'd say red flag number two was
probably like
they
he the ceo kept tweeting out these like
tech like a screenshot of a technical
scale test that they were doing was like
we could handle
you know 400 billion payments per you
know you know per second right now it's
like we can handle this many
transactions we got to go back to the
lab though and keep scaling up getting
ready for the big fast launch and i
remember thinking wow there's this
problem in silicon valley called
premature optimization where you're
prematurely you're planning for scale
when you don't have any skill yet
instead of just like going and getting
customers who actually want your product
to start using you and giving you
feedback you're planning for this like
fantasy world where everybody uses your
product and you can handle the scale
we're just going to call it we're just
going to call him
dom pre-jack from now on
exactly so so so me and me and fer we
were looking at this we're like this is
weird that he's pre-jacket over there
he's like we were just like i don't know
we just kind of shrugged our shoulders
at the beginning like when it first came
out i was like well honestly the idea is
a good idea like a single universal
one-click checkout will help
the whole world of e-commerce like go
forward you know it makes the customer's
life more convenient it makes websites
make more money like the idea makes
sense which is why
shopify has shop pay and that's why you
know bolt is worth billions of dollars
now like the idea is a good idea
and fast is a great brand name
and it seemed like that on paper this
guy was great because he was super high
energy he was building the brand and he
was uh he said his last company was like
he had something in his bio about 50
million
so anyways it all started to unwind more
recently when
two things happen the first is people
discovered that this guy dom who had
branded himself as dom there was a
reason he branded himself as dom because
if you used his full name dominic
holland if you just googled that you
would find all kinds of articles about
his previous company which basically was
the same thing it was a hype machine in
australia
and ended up losing a bunch of money
overnight getting sued and then he kind
of like ran away from the scene of the
crime in a way like and like not
necessarily left australia
and he didn't pay people back and uh
yeah it was it was
i think it was a gray hat for sure
potentially even illegal [__]
yeah there's like a 15 million dollar
dispute the government was like hey
we're owed something blah blah and the
same thing had a great domain toe.co
and so it's like this guy's like you
know good on the branding and the hype
side saying we he came out saying we're
uber for for basically like towing and
so he had the story he had his brand
toe.co
and then you know they basically left
with a 50 million legal dispute between
him and the state government over who's
supposed to pay for you know something
that's going on right so the company
goes under
so and so you know his his story was
like oh i built a successful company and
i remember because i tried to get him on
the podcast i dm them and i go hey what
you're doing fast seems interesting i'd
love to you know talk about investing
and then you know maybe have you on the
pod
but can we do a call i just want to like
understand your story
it was like kind of hard to get a hold
of him that he like we did a 10 minute
phone call and by the end of it i was
sort of like i don't know like
this guy's kind of like
he's a little bit fuzzy with the detail
so i was a little bit on the fence and
then he and he kind of sensed my
hesitation then he dmed me right
afterwards he goes you know what i think
we're not ready for press just yet
and like which was ironic right because
he's pumping it on twitter so like i
think he saw that i was kind of like
this seems like kind of [__] but
like okay yeah um that's the only alarm
was ringing
so anyways they the news just came out
about you know a about this guy's
background
um and then the second thing was that
fast is like very very small so fast has
i think a lifetime of 600 000 in revenue
is that right like with 300 employees
more 500 employees and six hundred
thousand dollars in revenue that's crazy
so
i had an interaction with them at when i
was running the hustle like a year and a
half ago i think it was i either me or
someone on my team i don't remember if
it was me that wrote it someone wrote
this ad
where it was like a video ad and it
it showed um it was like a magician you
know how they do the tricks where cards
are coming out of their mouth i think he
was doing it with money coming out of
his mouth or something like that and i
get a dm from someone and being like hey
fast ripped you off they took the ad
that we wrote and made and they copied
it shot for shot word for word and i
tweeted out that video and i was and i
tagged dom and his co-founder i forget
her name and i was like hey you guys
just totally ripped us off
and dom replied with just like a smiley
face and then the other co-founder was
like hey sorry about that sometimes and
then she named a person on their team i
forget sometimes blank gets a little bit
too carried away with the inspiration
and i was like oh you're just gonna
[__] call out this guy that who works
for you and then she dm to me and was
like like i'm not gonna ask you to take
it down but um
you know maybe if you let them know if
you could just tweet out saying that you
you
you know we deleted our ad or something
like that and uh i had a run-in with
them and i did not like that dom uh like
like objectively he has a super
punchable face
objectively
we're just talking objectively here
objectively like if if 9 out of 10
doctors recommend uh you know something
9 out of 10 people recommend that they
he he has a punchable face
let's watch this video to confirm uh
then play this video and kind of pause
after the ridiculous bit so my my buddy
matt uh sent this to me and he goes
this is before this news came out about
the like no revenue struggling to raise
money maybe gonna have a fire sale and
he's like
uh dude is this company serious like you
i remember you just talking about them
but like what the hell and he sent me
this obscure video from the tampa bay
journal because they moved to tampa
which first of all everybody's moving to
miami right now that's like the big move
tampa
they moved to tampa
is that that's the stock
it's like the socks and sandals capital
of the world
right
dude people love your socks and sandals
joke recently that's where we're going
to host a legacy conf
by the way the funny part is i do wear
slice of sandals in fact i love it all
right keep going
all right it's a little too choppy here
that's all right
pause it for a second
getting out of the car
he
crawled out of the window like a fetus
leaving the womb he okay so
the mayor or somebody's like fast is on
a rocket ship trajectory and
uh
what is this by the way is this a race
like a pickup truck it's a it's a i
think they call it stock trucks
basically it's a nascar basically
okay so
so
some car revving attention that has fast
dot co all over it
uh comes up does a donut and then the
ceo
crawls out the window and does a light
jog to the podium all right play it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god some guy puts a peach blazer
on him
no this guy his job
it's like yo yo peach me peach me and he
peached him with a peach blazer
and then
you know the paid crowd of people like
10 people all wearing fast t-shirts yeah
these these must be ordinary citizens
excited right
making the world better one check out a
time so much jim thank you for everyone
for coming truly thank you to parker my
uber driver parker kliegerman
he also moonlights as one of the fastest
nascar racers oh my god
suck some sandals
so fast forward a little bit get to the
jet ski
part basically he goes up there he gives
this speech
you know the city of tampa gives a
speech
oh my god
and then there's a stunt man on a jet
ski that says fast on it just going in
circles in the tampa bay
nice flip i gotta give them that
um so so this event happens and this is
just another thing where it's like
the more
parades you throw before you have
customers
like the bigger red flag you're throwing
up into the universe and so you know i
this is ridiculous uh this thing's about
to blow
uh the news has already started to leak
we called it you know many months ago
when we talked about this and uh you
know
it looks like it's going down soon yeah
this this had red flags all over it man
it's it is pretty ridiculous this is
crazy uh what what is it what's he
saying now is he has he said anything or
one of the employees saying anything
there's nothing on twitter about it from
from him that i saw so you know it's
kind of uh yeah his last tweet was like
oh they don't like this here's this new
customer that launched with us
um
that's crazy i'm so excited to see how
this ends man it is
you
we talked about this i talked about this
before so i've angel invested in over 50
companies you've done i imagine that or
more and um
it's easy to lie to people and i talked
about about this with you i was like hey
have you been lied to and i think you
said maybe once so far i've not been
lied to it is so easy to lie and it's so
easy
right i thought you said there was one
yeah i thought there was one person here
like i think they're lying
i don't remember that but uh maybe yeah
our point which is that like
silicon valley does very little
diligence at the early stages
and even at the later stages there's a
lot of like
dude it's a hot deal other big names are
in we're not doing uh you know basically
they're like tight timelines minimal
data sharing you're either in or you're
out and you sort of bet blind and during
bull markets
everybody just you know like it is
common practice for
people to uh to invest in stuff without
doing a ton of diligence and during the
you know bear markets when when the
leverage swings over to the side of
investors they're able to ask more
questions which dig in more and have
more time i'm not entirely hating on by
the way because i think you got to take
the go with the bad so the good or the
bad with the good what are the phrases
the the good is that like someone comes
to an investor and they'd be like hey i
have a track record of doing some
interesting things i don't even have a
product yet but my vision is is this and
the good is like there's people like me
and you and other people who are way
bigger than us who are like oh you know
screw it like you gotta you gotta take a
shot try it that's good and uh they'll
say look i don't have anything here but
let's try it so i understand that but
then the bad of it is you get [__] like
this
yeah exactly and honestly like if at the
time when i was reaching out to this guy
being like hey come on the pond and i
want to invest and all that stuff
because because again it really is a
good idea it's not that this is a bad
idea
and
you know at that time there was no
traction so there's not nothing due
diligence it's like it's pre-launch so
of course they have no customers of
course they have no revenue they just
launched and he pre-jacked all over the
place
and now it's uh it's much further along
and now you know sort of you see that
the emperor has no clothes and so um you
know but but i would say like it is very
common practice for this type of stuff
to happen and i think you know the well
i don't think i don't think it's common
though
it's not common that people lie like
that or are full of [__] i think i think
it's common that some people exaggerate
but in general i think the system
actually works
but yeah sorry that what i meant was
it's common that you invest without
having to
go diligence every claim that the
company makes and audit all their
financials and audit their customer base
and go do you know reference checks and
like
you don't do all that for the sake of
moving fast and in the in the aggregate
it totally works but then a few times
you're going to get egg on your face
that's just the cost of doing business
it's just the same way that you know one
percent of all credit card transactions
are fraud that doesn't mean credit cards
are bad it just means you have to bake
that into your model that you're gonna
have some issues like this and then in
general there's like there's the line
there's the gray hat of like
sort of fake it till you make it you
know you're forecasting optimistically
versus
actually misrepresenting something would
you invest someone
would you invest had you known that this
guy did what he did in australia so
let's say someone's being charged with
like fraud or something that is you know
related to fraud would you invest in
someone uh if they had that
usually not but it depends on the
situation like sometimes if
you know somebody's being sued
you got to take that a little lightly
because
uh people can get sued for anything it
doesn't necessarily mean i mean what
happened you sort of have to look into
this to the claims but yeah it's not
like a deal breaker in that sense of
like if somebody has some bad press
about them i don't necessarily like view
that as
an absolute no
but i have to like come clear with it
you know come to terms with it and i
think i've told the story before about
somebody who invested in hq trivia and
at the time i was like yeah i heard the
founders are like kind of uh you know
like there was some suspect stuff they
were like they had really gotten in
trouble at twitter for like berating
employees and stuff like that like they
got fired like there was some kind of
weird claims and they're like yeah we
looked into it we didn't find anything
that was like you know scared us away
and in fact the fact that it scared
other vcs away just makes us even more
bullish right like there's a there's an
honor in silicon valley of being a
contrarian which is like you know
being founder friendly and these things
can get you in trouble sometimes the
people the people who funded that they
called themselves contrarian it was uh
founders fund or some people related to
that and they they own a conference
called like contrarian conference
but you want to know the thing it's
called but yeah it is i think that's
what it's called the thing about
contrarians is they're wrong most of the
time right so uh
yeah i'm not surprised on that one um
well where do we go from here
um okay
do you have time listen two more topics
all right i want to get your quick take
on something i'm going to call this
segment
genius or idiot i want you to give me a
call is this more genius or more idiot
um
so by the way
i've gotten as the co-founder before we
get to genius i've gotten a fair bit of
feedback
on your drunk ideas the very long
distance girlfriend
fan favorite
and the big ass bed
oh dude by the way somebody somebody
reached out about the long distance
girlfriend very long right very long
distance they were like don't share this
don't share this oh yeah sorry very long
discord they said don't share this on
the pod but we we do this idea and they
showed us the numbers and the numbers
are super impressive so
that idea like legit is working on the i
wish we could talk about it but they
asked us not to all right genius or not
um all right so alex lieberman who's the
co-founder and ceo maybe of morning brew
um no chairman is that not right
chairman uh of morningbrew
came out and said uh he's looking at
buying mini golf courses so he's like
you know i'm interested in buying and
acquiring
uh putt-putt golf businesses
um
and he kind of had a couple of reasons
why i think he was like you know
um these are like recession resistance
like people need entertainment that's
cheap and fun
um you know these are like you know cash
flowing businesses and
you know probably not a ton of
competition so the prices are probably
reasonable
and there's like a real estate play
baked in those are his kind of like
reasons uh roughly if i was gonna gonna
articulate them for him and he said he
lost his reaction he said that he loves
putt-putt that's what he said like the
man loves to putt yeah so um first
reaction genius or idiot which way are
you going alex is a great guy i he's
very smart and i like him a lot uh he's
actually we become friends this is not
his best idea in my opinion
no i don't i don't think this is a good
idea you're being very very gentle
but so here's why so all right i'm an
internet person i made uh some money on
the internet now i'm currently at an
airbnb where i i'm getting into the
airbnb business
and what i'm learning is that it is
things like airbnbs and some other
businesses where they like you spit off
like
10 or 30 if you're really lucky a year
in cash flow those are awesome but
they're only they're more like just
growing your wealth quicker not
necessarily creating wealth or at least
it's a little bit more rare and what i'm
learning is like i was out here and i
just looked at my shopify thing and my
copy of that thing just made five grand
today and it's it'll do a hundred grand
a month maybe and i'm like okay well
a good month at my airbnb
will be like twenty or thirty thousand
dollars a month and i had to spend over
a million dollars i had to spend close
to two million dollars to buy it like
so
it's like
if i had to manage a
course i think it's tough so my friend
cody my good friend cody she does does
all this stuff cody sanchez and in my
head i'm like i just do not want to
manage all these people i think it's a
[__] nightmare it's incredibly
challenging and if you're alex lieberman
you're very you're that means you're
you're world class one of the best in
the country at creating newsletter
businesses i would stick to that maybe
or something related to that
so i'm uh so you're going 88 i'm going
genius with a caveat the genius move is
he already got all the value he's going
to get out of this tweeting that out was
the genius move because it makes him
sound interesting it's something kind of
fun he seems more basic just by tweeting
it out he's a more interesting guy than
just the newsletter guy i agree with
that
he comes across as kind of like fun and
rich because that's who goes out and
acquires putt-putt golf courses somebody
who's fun and rich
and uh he has currently no more work to
do besides typing the tweet out and so
if he stops here it's genius if he
crosses over and buys his first pup
golf course he has crossed the line
indeed no i have a fine line between
genius and individual he needs to take a
picture of him touring it dude when i
launched when i like just said i was
doing airbnb and i said here's the
property i'm about to close on that
tweet got read by two million people or
two million impressions and he does need
to milk it a little more so he needs to
like he needs to go to go to a few then
he needs to tweet out the economics of
how a public golf
business works so he'll learn himself he
should share that out just pour that out
then he should uh you know like maybe
like take a picture of him signing a
piece of paper and be like
we'll see new adventure
yeah new adventure new adventure new
chapter and then uh you know but like
you know he's signing
whatever the waiver and then he just
gives the owner two thousand dollars for
like a uh five percent share and he says
he owns block by course yeah
in his hometown he needs to do that in
his hometown and then all of his buddies
you need to be like hey i bought a piece
of uh let's go to alex's i'm an owner
i'm an owner and alex is putt and yeah
in majestic putt we're thinking about
changing it to alex's majestic putt but
like for now i just want to keep that
yeah
they're like you guys
we gotta go do the back nine at alex's
you guys want to go are you coming with
i have the keys we can go tonight yeah i
know the owner if you want at night we
can go yes
that's the true genius move
what's the next one
all right so uh the next one here elon
buys nine percent of twitter shares i
don't know if you saw that this morning
genius already oh he's going baller he
broke the scale he's going balls i'm not
even a
i'm not even an elon fan i i don't like
him for i i think some of his like jokes
about like 4 20 69 and telling a
politician their head looks like a penis
i think that's i'm not on board with
that i think that's silly i've also
because a it's not even funny and b
when you're have like people's pensions
invested in your company and you're like
doing dumb [__] like saying funding
secured at 420 not a fan of that but
this move
is
awesome i think what's the point having
it if you don't flex you know there's no
point in having few money if you don't
say a few once in a while i think this
is an awesome move i uh he's now the
largest shareholder so we spent three
billion dollars is that right
two or three billion dollars
yeah something like that maybe
not yeah yeah nothing for him and he
bought into twitter the stock is up 30
or 20 today so he's already made a
little bit a lot he's made a lot of it
and i think it's amazing i think that
he's all about this free speech guy i
actually think this is an amazing move
i'm very excited for it what do you
think
i think twitter's been undervalued by
the way i think it's genius as well
i agree with everything you just said
first of all i also think that elon's
kind of cheesy and cringy um when it
comes to like personality and i think
he's obviously
absolutely dope when it comes to his
business and like you know
you know like changing the world stuff
um
so you know yeah i think his his sort of
420 joke
and like you know 69 jokes that's sort
of like
uh
it's kind of like
if a normal person said that they would
not be funny yeah so it's only funny
because you're
you're rich and you're in business so
it's not like being like a hot podcaster
you're right you're not actually hot
you're a hot podcaster so it's kind of
like that sounds like a conversation you
just had it with someone
did someone but you you acted like like
well sean like
yeah you're a good-looking podcaster
yeah you've got a great voice
you're one of the best looking
podcasters
that's like okay you've got an amazing
hair for a tech person
i'm the smartest person at creighton
barrel
so
so basically uh yeah i think he's
changing some of those ways but i think
there's a baller move this is sort of
like when bezos bought like the
washington post or whatever and like you
know whoever benny off brought time
magazine and why
it's even better now than it was who
really wants to own an actual physical
newspaper like this is actually better
like just by twitter twitter is the
newspaper of the world and so just
buying like a big chunk of twitter and
being able to like
you know go swing you know yeah you know
go flex and that way i think that's a
i think that's a good move and i think
actually like
twitter could use um you know some
change and you know people always try to
build alternatives like trump tried to
build a truth social as like an
alternative to twitter
crash the other day but the stock did
yeah but
but a better move is just to buy twitter
and like you know if if your
ultra rich buy twitter institute the
changes you want there because all the
people are already on it right how much
uh
how much stock do you have to own in
order to have your opinion be heard if
you own 10 i think there's like some
legal
stuff around 10 right
i don't know exactly what it is but i
think there's like it depends how much
it's like he owns x percent of the float
but i think it's you need to own the
voting shares which is like you may not
own the same percent of voting shares as
you do total shares and the second thing
is i think basically what you do is you
become sort of an activist investor
which basically says you get on the
board or you you sort of lobbied the
board to make a ceo change and the ceo
needs the ceo that gets installed is a
ceo that kind of carries out the agenda
that you have in mind otherwise they're
also going to get fired by the by the
activist investors so so you know i
think that's the the general idea i
don't think he's going to play it
exactly like that i think he's just
going to be very vocal about what he
what he thinks they should do which is
a lot around fixing freedom of speech
and like the algorithm being either open
sourced or choose your own algorithm so
that you're not you don't have to listen
to twitter's filter you can choose your
own filter or you can know how the
filter works at the very minimum dude
i'm on board with this i think this is
great so i think that's what he's trying
to do on board genius and by the way i
think this is the only other stock he
owns
so i think before i've heard him on an
interview say that he owns only tesla
spacex
bitcoin and ethereum
and now this is this would be the only
other stock he directly owns if uh if he
was not bullshitting that first time
that's crazy what a crazy person oh
okay i have another um
sort of genius or idiot thing
did you see that logan paul was at
wrestlemania genius i did and i watched
it it was awesome
and it's actually not a part of genius
or idiot this is actually a part of like
a different question is logan paul the
greatest athlete of our generation did
you see this video so he looked great he
looked so good he looked amazing so so
he did three suplexes in a row
i haven't watched wrestling since
like 20 years wrestling is back
wrestling is like booming but wrestling
is [__] back dude is back in a huge
way
and i think there's a lot of
opportunities around the fact that
wrestling is back and but the whole
world has changed it's like wrestling is
back but the entire world and the way it
works has changed and so that to me says
there's a lot of opportunity because
like you have crazy fandom and passion
but like all new like tools at your
disposal for like how you could like
harness that energy so they did
wrestlemania yesterday and whatever i
saw a bunch of clips you know stone cold
steve austin came back and drank a bunch
of beers uh pat mcafee was also a
podcaster somehow was like a key person
in the thing i don't know why somebody
can explain that to me but logan paul
did a match and ben if you pull up the
clip of logan paul in this wrestling
match
unbelievable athlete
absolutely unbelievable yeah it was
amazing and he did all the acting and
stuff he didn't he killed it yeah dude
they killed it i thought that was really
good by the way not easy to do what he
was doing what's it called it's not the
wwf wwe i think they uh that's a
publicly traded company yeah and so you
could like and you can buy it by their
stock and it's a killer business it it
they crush it
yeah i mean vince mcmahon is kind of an
unbelievable story in and of itself but
incredible athlete and a great crossover
move the paul brothers continue
to just not miss so i think you know i
think
like logan paul i think his podcast now
one of the most popular podcasts in the
world and more importantly than like oh
the paul brothers did something and i
got a bunch of views like that's a good
podcast though
but it's a good podcast and it's actual
it's actually entertaining content it's
actually like deeper content they talk
to all different types of people from
like business people musicians porn
stars they've had like all different
types of people and they have like
full-on conversations so then
it's a rebrand right it's like basically
taking this guy used to be a vine star
making fart jokes
and now you see
you know a more mellow side and a more
thoughtful side and all this other stuff
um
look at him he is yolked
logan paul is yoked yeah and as a kid i
remember watching this look at him do
all that [__] do you dude these guys are
basically
bodybuilders who
have personalities they are so freaking
big they're
they're bodybuilders that are soap opera
actors that also can do are like also
like cirque du soleil acrobats basically
dude they're unicorns
did uh like some crazy [__] in this
match anyways people should go watch it
is honestly impressive just to see the
physical feat that he pulled off in this
thing
um
so i thought that was impressive and i
also think it's a smart move or an
influence like this was not what they've
done with like going into celebrity
boxing
deep podcasting they've won crypto nfts
pokemon cards and then going into uh
like jake has a venture fund logan is
going to wwe now and like building his
character up there they're talking about
potentially doing a ufc fight like these
guys have like these guys are winning
man they're winning at like a very high
level that is very impressive to me um
and you know
most people just write them off like
they're idiots they're not idiots these
guys are awesome the thing about logan
is i actually like i've been watching
his podcast he like he's he's done a
really good job of rebranding himself he
is
he still has a little bit but he's
mostly he's not like a douche he's not a
bro he's super thoughtful he's he seems
like a really nice person he's the
respectful one on the podcast he's got
these kind of goofball friends that are
like a little more brash and annoying
they can ask questions and like joke
around about stuff
but he's the more reserved almost like
introverted like thoughtful 26 mature
person 25 he's not that old but he like
he like gives advice like uh he seems
like he's just it's there's a lot of
stuff there that's rooted in pretty good
values you could just tell that his
brother i don't pay attention to as much
but logan i definitely um have been
watching his stuff and he seems very
very uh like a good dude
right yeah super impressive um all right
let's do uh one last thing uh i have
this this little life advice tip which
is
i believe that everybody needs to have a
treat yourself budget
and what is a treat yourself budget okay
so basically this is part of uh the
overall skill of learning how to spend
money and your friend jason just did it
wonderfully spending money is a skill
and we so here's what here's
my story around this so my dad
was great you know good at making money
right he came into the country i think
with like i don't know
91 dollars and that was like all he had
as his like starting point and like he
ended up making millions of dollars in
his lifetime
and
he learned how to make it but he didn't
he never learned how to spend it you
know if i go you know to a coffee shop
with my dad my dad's first thought is
like this is mostly water and like i can
make this at home
and like they're just charging you for
the brand and the cup and you know he's
like talking himself out of a three
dollar cup of coffee when he actually
wants a coffee
and so you know like if there was a free
coffee he'd walk two miles to go get it
and so you know he wants the coffee but
he doesn't know how to spend
and so spending i've learned is actually
a skill
and so i think one way you can get
better at the skill like anything else
is to practice so how do you practice
spending well
uh
i have this idea of a treat yourself
budget so at my last startup we created
a bonus program at bibo and basically i
don't remember what it was exactly i
think it was like a thousand dollars a
month at the uh was like
the low end and then basically as the
company grew i would multiply the bonus
pool so like when our user base doubled
the bonus pool doubled as well and um
and so we would give out this bonus and
the only rules the only strings attached
with bonuses
you have to spend it on something
interesting that you weren't otherwise
going to buy yourself anyways so you
can't just pay rent groceries your
student debt can't do it sorry
uh you got to buy something you weren't
otherwise going to do it and then you
got to come tell the story after you
after you buy it
and so jason was the first winner of the
thing couldn't have been a better better
guy to win it
and um he was like trying to debate what
to do and i told him i said he was like
what's some of the he goes what's
something you spent like a thousand
dollars on that like
like punched above its weight and i told
him i go you know when i first got named
ceo of the company i like i was like
okay i'm making more money and i'm you
know like how do i like mark this new
chapter and i was like i'm no longer
like a college kid anymore but i still
dress like a college kid so i had hired
a personal stylist i went on craigslist
i said hey i want somebody to come to my
house
uh take away all the clothes that suck
and buy me new clothes that look awesome
and i said send pictures of like what
you think awesome style what's like uh
what's like the statue of limitations on
that because it doesn't look like you uh
are our followers this was a decade ago
this is a decade ago so
this lasted i think two years did she
buy you cut off attack
did was she like all right uh you're a
cut off a t-shirt a cutoff t-shirt type
of guy jordan shorts let's go over to
foot locker i think we'll we'll make you
look nice
dude i gotta say it was insane i put
that up on craigslist i woke up the next
morning i had 81 replies in my inbox
and i was like wow there's and it was
mostly it was like half people who were
like oh i work in retail or i'm a
stylist or something and half of it was
like dude i wish my guy friends would
let me do this i'm just like it's just
like a girl who's like i know how guys
should dress better
and guys dress horrible and i wish my
friends would let me do this sounds like
you're gonna let me do this like i'll do
it but i ended up picking this like
really hot russian model to
do it
she had great a great sense of style she
came to she came to my house she went to
my closet and she just took everything
out and was like do you have garbage
bags at the house oh my god oh yeah yeah
let me just go get them and i was like
but that one's my high school jersey
she's like yeah it looks like a high
school jersey uh you know like you're
gonna throw it away for that for exact
reason
and she's like did you wear this to prom
and i was like yeah that's my good
that's my good shirt
she's like
this shirt sucks
basically she
yeah go ahead so we did this at the
hustle so check this out and then look i
want to hear what jason did so basically
we did the same thing every month we
would have it like it was like
a thousand dollars and one person can uh
vote how the group will spend it like
we'll all do something together maybe it
was more than a thousand i don't
remember one time when we had i think 12
employees our office was down the street
from costco
and we basically people teamed up in
teams of two so they're
maybe we had 20 people i don't remember
but i think we gave each person each
group 200
and we said
starting now you've got 20 minutes and
you got to go buy something and at the
end we're going to vote on who got the
best thing and like i went and bought
like and i oh and i think it was 100 you
had to spend on something that wasn't
food and the other 100 you had to spend
on something that was food and we're
gonna go eat together and vote on what
the winning thing is and so people like
bought all this stuff that like you
don't really want up like the big cheese
ball things like you don't want to bite
at your house but you've always wanted
to try it right and it was the most fun
team building activity we've ever had it
was awesome
that is that is genius um i was just
talking to somebody like uh the guy who
runs our warehouse and he's like oh yeah
you know
people want another you know
this other warehouse amazon warehouse is
offering an extra two dollars an hour
these guys are complaining that it's
cold inside and i feel like it's hard to
hire people because people don't want to
work anymore
and i was like dude
i get it i get it but you got to be
creative about how to make this fun for
people and you got to figure out how to
take this many dollars and make it feel
like a trillion dollars of budget for
you and the thing you just described
cost you probably like a thousand or
twelve hundred dollars but like
you're still talking about it like ten
years later it was amazing
every single
remembers it it was super fun great team
bonding probably liked some of the stuff
that you you got and like and then it's
just such a simple way to like go go
further it morphed into eating contests
somehow so every month we would have an
eating contest and we had one lady who
worked for us who ate i swear to god 12
krispy kreme donuts in seven minutes and
then went to the bathroom and
like just annihilated it and she had to
go home because she was sick so it
wasn't the most productive but people
loved it and then we would do the last
thing that we would do is we would do
taste tests so for example we would buy
every single bottle of water that this
nice grocery store near our office had
and you had to see who can guess which
bottled water is which we had another
guy that he would win 100 if he could
guess the difference in all the grapes
because he was like oh i could tell the
difference in all the grapes i'm like i
don't know man i don't think you can we
did the same thing with app and then we
did this like a blind taste test yeah
like which grape is this and then we did
the same thing with apple so they had to
guess which apple it was and if you got
it right you'd get 100 and stuff like
that was the most fun
yeah
sam this is why this is why you need to
be teaching business school instead of
you know whatever professors teach in
business school because the stuff like
this that actually matters to people
actually make the work environment more
fun and uh you know they don't teach you
this at school so so i i am with you
dude these like cheap there's like cheap
ways where it's not about the money it's
about the creativity and the fun and the
kind of like the humor of it that makes
it uh that makes it hit there's this
book and there's this book called um
man's search for meaning have you read
it
it's like really sad part of it it's
like wait you read the cover yeah uh
it's it's like way deeper than the [__]
that we're talking about but basically
it's about like a jewish guy who was a
psychiatrist or something and he went to
the concentration camp for four years
and so it's kind of interesting because
he's like oh i'm my own experiment and
what he said was that the people who
survived best
or the people who died would basically
say we're gonna get uh released uh on
christmas i think we're gonna get
released on christmas and then christmas
would come and pass and they would get
all depressed and bummed and they
wouldn't have anything to look forward
to and they would die uh just like you
know just get worn down and then the
other people who are like i'm getting
out of this and when i get out of this
i'm going to become a doctor so i can
make sure that no one's harmed like this
again or i'm going to get out of this so
i can see my loved ones i'm going to get
out this way
i could tell the world about this and
write about it and he said that every
person that survived they all most of
them had a thing to look forward to and
so i kind of stole that tactic it
doesn't exactly apply here but i was
like for my office we're gonna have a
calendar and we're gonna make sure we
list all the activities and so people
always have something to look forward to
and i noticed that that actually changed
the morale so you want do you want to
have something to look forward to so
then when you're eating lunch you're
like hey in two weeks is that thing have
you thought about where you're gonna buy
at costco and that type of stuff really
really helped
probably not the best to compare it to a
concentration camp but yeah it was you
learned it from there i learned it from
that book it's a great book
um yeah it was the end of the story it
doesn't really have a point but
basically jason hired a jason when jason
won i was like you should do this thing
he did it he loved it first of all he's
like dude the experience
it's it's it's like that scene from
pretty woman where you just get to walk
into the store you know you're gonna buy
up a storm you don't even really have to
think like the stylist when i did it she
was like go to the dressing room i'm
going to hand you things you put them on
and i was like she'd hand me something
like i don't know i don't really wear
stuff like this she's like yeah i know
that's the point
and then you know i'd wear the thing and
then you know i get to see it sometimes
i hated it and sometimes i liked it
she'd never make you buy something you
didn't like but she would always make
you try stuff that you don't normally
wear or whatever and so jason came back
to work looking super cool
uh he was wearing like all of a sudden
he had like rings and like you know
jackets and like you know this is the
ring guy now
he's a big ring guy and he had like you
know like these like look like you know
whatever like these chains that like his
mom didn't buy them and uh and anyway so
he looked cool and he had just like the
right amount of swag to it and he was
saying something um on twitter that i
thought was just like a very
uh like a good way of putting anybody to
say he goes
um
he goes
uh where'd he go what did he say he goes
most guys don't know how to style
themselves it's worth being taught life
was more fun if you're excited about
what you wear every day especially if
you know that the outfit you're wearing
like amplifies the impression that
you're trying to make it gives you more
presence
and like most people don't like to say
this stuff out loud but that's part of
jason's superpower is he's like
completely unashamed of the things he
feels and says and so he was able to
like articulate it well so anyways
somebody's listening to this do you have
the budget um something i highly
recommend doing you will feel different
and it's a good experience uh to go give
yourself a great way to treat yourself
but even if you're even if you don't do
that create a treat yourself budget
create like it doesn't matter if it's a
hundred dollars
a thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars
start with even like a hundred dollars
and be like oh am i gonna spend a
hundred dollars on something that i
wouldn't otherwise
have done for myself i didn't need
but will give me some new experience
it'll take me in some different
direction even a slightly different
direction in life uh it can make a big
difference that guy's name is jason
hitchcock he's a good follower on
twitter because he's living his best
life right now he's having a good time
yep
all right that's all i had for today
all right that's the episode
[Music]
you